tell me about yourself
young girl did you know that this was
what you're interested in you're
interested in writing you're interested
in creating did you know at a young age
this is for you or is it something
you've figured out later on
um I think I knew at a young age I knew
that I liked to make people laugh
because and and that would be I guess
the big family thing wouldn't it yes
um so I did very bad Impressions and you
know would do them for my my mum and dad
and
um you know I I like to write but I
think I thought my my path was was
acting and and you know comedy acting
specifically that was what I was kind of
drawn to and uh
gosh it just took so long and nothing
was happening you know I know this about
you and it doesn't make sense to me that
it took so long because well
um you I just
the minute I saw you and saw your work
it just felt like well of course this
woman is a big deal so the concept of
you
waiting around for any period of time
and nobody's seeing it see I was kind of
crazy yeah I think I was like
36 or something
um when I got um pulling which is our
first um thing that um Dennis Kelly and
I wrote but
um yeah previous to that but then I have
to say I think it was also my fault I
think I was just not very good at
putting myself out there or or you know
kind of done a bit of had work on it and
thought well maybe I was sort of worried
about failing or something you know so
that if I if I put myself out there and
and if I tried and I failed then then
that's it at least if I kept putting it
off and just like getting stoned or
whatever right
um then then maybe I could say well I
haven't given it a proper go yeah you
know right so possibly that have you
done therapy have you have you explored
therapy um I I do it more now
um not not so much because Freud
famously said
the only people that are immune to
therapy are the Irish
really yeah and
um I would like to think he was wrong
because I've had a ton of it but he just
thinks that we're
he uh I think he just thought yeah those
Irish they I can't crack them
do you know where that like well did it
just come from him get a few bad kicks
I don't know what it was I don't know
where it comes from I may have seen this
quoting him but I've often heard this
quote that that he said that uh yeah the
Irish the you know like therapy will
work on anyone not be Irish and it kind
of makes sense to me because all my
friends who went and saw banshees of
initial and came away and said oh my God
what Madness what Madness you know the
throwing
fingers at the door and the donkey dying
and just Madness in this ridiculous spat
over nothing and I watched the movie and
said yeah that adds up
this show is sponsored by better help so
I know you're uh very busy yeah you've
got twins yes twins who are over two now
they're gonna be two in July it's very
easy to find yourself uh doing things
for other people or trying to be really
productive and get a lot done and take
care of everybody I know you're a
caretaking personality yeah I am so are
you and and what happens sometimes is
you'd realize I haven't checked in on
myself I have no clue how I'm doing yeah
I bring this up because I'm a big
believer in talk therapy if you if you
can find the right fit right person and
getting help it's made a huge difference
in my life yeah in some ways I've been
your therapist over the years you have
been you've been and I and I think that
you're as you didn't want to pray I
don't want to pay someone so I figured I
could just talk to you I'll just do it
for free but it is so it is important to
talk to someone if you're thinking of
starting therapy maybe give better help
a try here's what I like about
betterhelp it's entirely online this
didn't exist back in the day when I was
maybe looking for someone to talk to and
it's such a smart way to get involved in
this process better help is designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule find more balance with
better help I really think this is a
terrific idea visit betterhelp.com Conan
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan but yeah it is
we had confession I suppose right you
know just go into a little box and say
everything you did wrong I mean I think
that's how I do therapy really I mean I
I I always assume I'm doing it wrong
yeah anyway
um it's isn't it really just someone
making you feel okay about your bad
choices yes
it is you're paying someone to say you
know
plenty of people uh abandon their family
and uh go on a nine day cocaine binge in
Las Vegas and then shoot up at a hotel
and then uh California yeah exactly kill
a prostitute but then in order they'd
say
are you sorry you'd say yes and you get
some six helmets to say and then you're
you're all like you've got a clean slate
yeah I haven't been to confession in a
long time but I remembered
uh thinking what metric are they using
to figure out how many Hail Marys how
many I don't know and it was so specific
like you know I you know I I got this
rental car and I scraped it up a bit but
then I covered it with white out and um
oh yeah that would be for our fathers
and six Hail Mary yeah and then you'd
say oh and on the way back I ran into a
a whole bunch of people at a crosswalk
and fled the scene okay seven him
yeah at what point did they just call
the police no I mean I haven't been to I
I stopped confession quite young
actually because it did
um freak me out it's scary
I found it very scary and I remember
telling my mum that I that I found it
scary and she's very sweet about it
because she's a you know pretty
religious lady and uh so I said look
I'll keep going to mass but I don't want
to I don't want to do the confession
thing
um in in my car I went to convent school
um The Sacred Heart and um they would do
big um confession like Galas where in
our Sports Halls like all priests from
all around the area
um I don't know maybe there was a couple
of Cardinals or
um they would they would um fill the
hall and we would all
um they'd be all like situated at
different spots and you'd get into these
big queues all all the all the students
would be in the middle and you get into
these queues and you'd be like oh which
priest have I gotta get and you can make
your way up and then you would confess
to them and then you would confess and
it was kind of felt a bit out in the
open because you know you're not in a
box like you normally are that's so
insane it's take it I mean in this
country what you were describing is a
pep rally it's it's a it's an event
where people get together and go go team
and and maybe some Punch or a prom and
uh you guys turned it into a you queue
up to talk to a priest about something
terrible about your sins yeah yeah but I
hope but drinks are served I'm hoping
well you know when you're when you're
little and you do it you kind of you end
up making them up like I would that's
what I did
yeah because you're just okay I mean you
don't really do any bad when you're
okay I mean apart from
I mean obviously there's some evil
children out there yeah but
um no but there's uh
uh I I it's funny you say that because I
distinctly remember making things yeah
and sometimes I got too creative and I'd
say you know I forged a banknote and
they'd be like well
you know I committed wire fraud I would
say things just to try and you know that
I had heard about that I didn't know or
you'd use things you'd read like I there
was a pie cooling on the Oh by the open
window the year was 1932 and I stole a
pie from a cooling window and then lived
down by the train tracks and ate beans
out of a can